hello and welcome to this video playing
a national master da Silva and I've got
those national titles nowadays in on the
SSC coffee tea coffee tea time probably
musician songwriter poet rapper okay so
let's see what we won't forget norris
playing the cons variation yeah this is
probably the best line against that's
the problem for me is that my knowledge
ends here i really i really don't know
anything anything detailed Disick's
however i have recently seen I think
white is better here but I have one
issue my development is not all that
great this one probably should develop a
piece d fiber something that is a little
bit boring ok so videos goes for and
this kind of setup a dark squared set up
katraj own control before I wonder this
one we should be three maybe yeah this
looks like quite a decent setup for
black I wonder what my plan is maybe I
should move the Queen this is clam but i
can go i think i should i go here for
let's go for the normal square queen a3
looked interesting as well having a look
at that pawn but it looked a little bit
too to be it for my taste yeah so if you
would get in night c5
95 b6 it would be fine but I wonder what
he is doing against me doubling now I
just double now on the D file this isn't
funny case I mean you would usually say
if there's a bishop on your 7 that is a
big bad bishop but believe me black
would love to have a bishop on your 7
now for some stupid night to get these
six covered one of those bad bishops
protect good points things I don't
really see how it keeps the pawn to be
honest maybe it's some some weird
maneuver but it could be something maybe
some tactic or you can maybe sacrifice
it Queen you have six Queen d6 Luke the
eight but I don't think that this can be
objectively enough ok so he tries to a
second somehow or maybe get a 5 going ok
anyway I'll play if I go that can go be
three okay c4 was hanging if I would
have taken d6 Bishop takes Bishop takes
rook takes the night was hanging and
this was something that put me put me
off a little bit ok um he maybe has b5
coming him maybe
but root g 1 p-5 i play night a three
and Isis still a pretty pretty much a
disaster attacking b5 and if you takes
it now it's ok pawn takes Bishop takes I
still don't see how these six is going
to be cut to be kept here night a three
is unstable but I don't think he could
have attacked at 45 looks terrible here
as well so that NT six is just dropping
now and II five and a six hour hanging
as well I probably win a second porn now
I can take c 5 and 8 67 I think it's a
bit of a shame to give that Bishop on
but second pawn is too tempting
gets to d for him I wonder I sense up
some later prevent that it's a little
bit make the conversion a bit trickier
check check and form it's probably
helpful undermining the night so taking
it on and also gain a more space host
do six check check check
black resins and I think this is opening
your earnest very interesting with Queen
d3 I think this is a serious issue for
this opening for black it has also been
played by the cards as well championship
match against rashad and honored went
for something for some pretty bleak
ending I think I think we played this
jackman and that that didn't that was a
pretty awful position for black that was
the famous game with the double blonde I
am where they both blundered and it was
extremely important for the outcome of
that match but if you just look at the
opening that was a huge success form for
wide okay this I think not c 2 is
correct what I saw I looked at this just
yesterday actually from the black side
and I concluded that after night see to
it doesn't look too great yeah and here
I think white why should be somewhat
better black black decided to play in a
very slow manner now with this and I
think you probably should try d 5 or or
b-five maybe this is what the engine
suggests this looks quite good actually
computer gives this but this this is
interesting black has a good development
maybe this is still better what the
engine suggests it felt very slow to me
after d5 but maybe it doesn't matter why
its development it's not that great but
this is the thing in this position if
white is not getting checkmated in the
next hello 10 moves his position is
fantastic he's got the better structure
to bishops control over deform the dark
squares and so on so this is either
explodes or white some almost wins so
here if I've this is probably too slow I
mean I just made this play plant this
very simple stuff against Cindy pawn and
it felt like it's probably over the
computer agrees
it gives a white already a very big
advantage here now b5 and okay the
computer actually just wants to check
these six but this isn't bad either
right yeah it's also very good here okay
96 but was even strong word this is a
completely winning ending anyway yeah so
this baby is a good tip for the white
player if you want to if you want to
play here the right side of this is a
very good line 23 and I don't like black
I think it seems has trouble to equalize
them ok guys thanks for watching